brought to you by PlayStation Store
access to the ultimate and games and
entertainment worlags the handsome
collection hallo master chief edition
Grim Fandango remastered Resident Evil
remastered I have a lot more written
down here but god there's a lot of
remasters lately what's the deal with
that joining me on the couch to talk
about that alexa ray korea Peter Brown
and Justin hey old hello all name some
other remasters that I miss Fantasy
type-0 a cry for don't look okay good
resident evil HD do we say that I
totally said that one but it was not the
right title anyways I well I mean you're
saying a lot of remasters that serve
different purposes like summary masters
are like grim fandango is something we
hadn't seen in years like decades like
that was something that this is the
first time that so many people got a
chance to even experience this game
whereas some games like Grand Theft Auto
is technically a remaster of the 360 ps3
game but that thing you know that came
out like last year so what purposes does
a remaster serve you name one
resurrecting a game that's you know from
way far back but they were not what all
of them do or like type 0 has never been
released in north america so HD was its
first North American do reaching new
audiences be it in new regions or on new
consoles what else we got finally you
take a game that came out for a system
where developers are constantly pushing
the system to the limits on the next
generation of consoles you have a
remaster they can finally take off some
of those shackles the game will perform
better and look better and maybe play
better too and we see a big difference
between summary masters that that really
go all out like that just completely all
in some ways redefine the world or
approach in ways that were impossible on
previous hardware and then you also have
some remasters where minimal amount of
work is done or or really releases I
guess I you wouldn't call that a
remaster earthbound is something that
comes to mind which you know hadn't been
released in a long time was put out on
the Virtual Console after a long absence
nothing additional is at it like it is
just literally here's the game on
Nintendo's Virtual Console you know a
platform that lets you experience the
these older games and re-released form
so the reason we're talking remasters is
I mean Borderlands is out now that
includes a game that we
is the pre-sequel came out in October
but it was actually only available for
360 ps3 now it's on xbox one ps4 but god
of war 3 going to be remastered for the
ps4 Batman Arkham Asylum and Arkham City
slated to rumored to be coming out by
Christmas this year with Arkham Knight
coming out in the middle of this year
now this is an interesting one because
you're kind of like what what does a
remaster what purposes remaster serve
and what risks does it run when you're
working on the remaster of the game and
a new edition of the of that's in that
series at the same time well a remaster
can introduce a set like Justin was
saying a generation of gamers that
hadn't been exposed to it before like
grim fandango and we're getting day the
tentacle soon same thing with the Metal
Gear collection that came out I think
last year where it was all of them
together and that's great but some of
them like you mentioned the borderlands
handsome collection and I think that's a
cash grab because the pre-sequel came
out last year for previous gen and then
were using it at six months later less
than six months later for current-gen
and that to me feels kind of like
shameless and gross like why didn't you
just come out with it then yeah well
let's be honest right like publishers
have demands when it comes to shipping a
game perhaps those versions weren't
ready I think it's also fair to say that
not everyone plays every game that comes
out all the time sometimes we miss those
games and especially you have a
generational shift for consoles a lot of
people put those old systems away if
they wanted to get into a game from the
past they have the option to do that on
a current hardware versus the old one so
I don't I mean yeah it's a cash grab
because these games are money right that
that's how my publishers fun games and
release them and I don't know that it's
necessarily a bad thing I think it's
kind of giving people more options when
it comes to the console of choice
exactly I cash-grab isn't necessarily a
negative innocence like this is
something that is helping fund these
publishers like that they're getting new
life in games that they spent years
developing and if you want more games
that series that both shows the
developer that you still care about this
franchise or that you're still willing
to give it a chance and then then we can
get a sequel because will they have an
influx of money and they have the
support of the fans who maybe didn't try
it before or maybe just want to
experience it again right before that
new iteration that new version
comes up and in terms of the resources
devoted to ya a remaster versus an
entirely new game you're talking about a
whole different scale of operation very
different cuz they're not redesigning
the game I mean for the most part what
they are doing are taking old textures
and updating them perhaps having an
engineer going there and update some of
the the filters not the filters but the
the stuff behind the rendering tech
right so that'll apply anti-aliasing all
upscale those those a you know the
rendering frame buffer and stuff so that
could be a small team and if it takes
that small team to make that much more
money to like he's saying support the
future of a series or a publisher I
think that's a positive thing if that's
an option that people are willing to
support of course that depends on if the
remaster all goes well and is developed
and if you launch this properly of
course halo the master chief collection
that it's online woes and we've seen
other remasters that they aim is to
improve technical prowess but maybe it
doesn't quite hit the mark so you know
and sometimes we want more like I think
one of the more recent examples of a
remaster or an HD remake that
disappointed so many people its final
fantasy 7 like it's you know a game that
we've wanted for so long and then
they're announcing here's final fantasy
7 HD and you keep waiting for those
graphics to change to something that
looks modern and it never does and like
oh it's it's the pc version that's
slightly better looking well the amount
of money that they would have to spend
too late and the resources that would go
into completely remaking that is just
that's any game that you need you mean
the resources they'd have to spend to
make any game for a modern console at
strip away it doesn't matter that it's
that is the remaking Apollo fantasy 7 if
they're gonna make any game that's new
and exciting it's going to be as
ambitious if not more ambitious then
that game was nearly 20 years ago I
don't know I think the whole remasters
thing is getting other hand like I think
publishers need to trust that if they
have someone out there who wants to play
final fantasy 7 until the end of days
that they'll keep the hardware for it I
know I do that I don't you guys do that
well well going back to I think a point
the Chris made I'm actually really
excited about some upcoming remasters
because there are so many games that
especially because of our job I just
didn't have time to play or they were on
generations they like that kind of
passed me by Gears of War is not
something that's announced I I assumed
like that has to be happening that's
there's been so many rumors for so long
I actually kind of want that I never
played the Gears of War series and
hang on you know a next-gen console
sounds pretty fun like I can't imagine
that would be bad master chief
collection is another 1i missed so many
of those Halo games I'm looking forward
to just playing through the entire
series on a current gen system I don't
have to keep my older systems plugged in
it's it's easier to access and I know it
looks better i know it's supported that
it's gonna look right i mean some of
them have problems when they come out
like master chief collection but given
enough time and in the support of the
fans who are behind it like those
versions get to be better like they can
replace that in my in my library so i
don't have to have all these machines
plugged in and again you know having
those old machines plugged in you know
you can get it i get a copy of the game
cheap and may play the older version of
it uh but you need the older machines
plugin there was a time in this industry
that backwards compatibility was a thing
it was like a brief shining moment it
gone forever more uh it seems you guys
like remasters and backwards
compatibility but you know did you think
you saw that as sort of like we're not
making us your money off the backwards
compatibility yeah here's ways we can I
don't see like that I mean that's got
that's got way more to do with a
hardware code base issue than them
saying let's not do that way let's do it
this way let's hold on to it and charge
they would have to write so many
different tools to take the language for
one system to port it to another in the
case of going from powerpc-based
architecture of xbox 360 and ps3 to the
now x86 architecture of these new
consoles it it's simply not financially
feasible at that point I mean you look
at the solution for the original ps3 to
get ps2 compatibility was to literally
put in ps2 architecture inside exactly
station 3 it's like that you're not
making enough money for it and enough
people aren't using it to make that
worthwhile whereas emulation or things
like PlayStation now services like the
Virtual Console that give you access to
that back library allow the developer to
make some money off of it without you
know losing all of that to use games but
still allow you to experience those
games in a way that for me it doesn't
clutter up my living room do you guys
think a remaster could ever be
detrimental to a series I don't I mean
if it's it's bad it's bad it depends if
they're marketing it as something you
know completely redone and polished and
then you get something that's super
janky like master chief collection or
I know in Borderlands the handsome
collection the priests Eagles incredibly
janky to look at oh yeah so the friends
like especially when you get four
players playing that the framerate can
definitely suffer because you could sour
goodwill yeah it seems that not rare but
especially with the master chief
collection like I definitely recognize
where everyone was so hyped and then
felt so burned and so some of it also
comes down to do these games hold up
like nostalgia is such a powerful thing
like grim fandango is as a game that i
loved growing up and like I don't know
if I want to try this again and it
definitely was harder going back I mean
it's beautiful and the writing is still
amazing but there's a lot that did not
age well about that game the really long
animations the traveling back and forth
across the stage like those things don't
hold up well in modern game design even
even though the overall structure is
great and so it's like this gives you a
chance to go back and play these games
but sometimes taking the extra time to
to really remaster it instead of just
kind of rerelease it can give you a
better experience that nostalgia will
tell you was there absolutely all right
let's end on a positive note tell me
some of your favorite remasters that you
have either played or are looking
forward to easy shadow of the colossus
shadow of the colossus yeah it's a
beautiful game and just going it going
from 480p to 10 or I don't know if it's
720 or 1080 doesn't matter a game was
beautiful and it came out and was made
even more beautiful by being remastered
mm-hmm on the PlayStation 3 with the
team ico collection yes The Last of Us
remastered was well I mean it was a
wonderful game to begin with it was
wonderful revisiting again and but I and
I would still but I was like a year
after don't person came out that's
called well I have a really short memory
grand theft auto 5 is well I joris mask
oh oh no that is my favorite sure his
mask Majora's Mask very good to play
that again after so many years I was
when I was so scared wasn't gonna live
up to my expectations because I that was
my favorite Zelda game what it did it
was so well done all right any remaster
announcement predictions for this year
uncharted collection on charter
collection is yeah we're gonna get a
charter collection we're probably gonna
get wrath of the big things this year
that are coming out good uncharted
collision here's a good track let's look
to console games are
also on PC because then there's a really
good chance they're going to work with
the architecture the new consoles which
are pretty similar for the most part
mm-hmm I'm hoping for Miller gear rising
revengeance because that kind of pc
release that came in so video with that
yeah yeah and like if they can get that
at 1080p 60 frames per second I think in
the very near future is a good chance
we're gonna see blood-borne HD for the
ola xbox one and pc you heard it rumored
here first folks all right thank you
guys for coming on chat and remaster